[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum it's funny i was just
playing a song and then ryan goes
who's that i go it's de barge like i was
gonna know
and he was like i don't know because you
know them you're like no i don't
rarely do i get them right it's all
right it's an 80s thing man i'm lost in
the 80s
i'm lost in emotion do you get that
reference to lost in emotion
anyway that's lisa lisa and the cult jam
off the coast
uh hopefully you're enjoying your week
your weekday
your weekend uh and you're feeling good
and you're doing stuff for yourself man
uh you know i've been going through the
surgery it's like a week and a half now
and uh
starting to feel a little bit better
thank you for all the wishing wells
kiss and tells it's another song from
the 80s or maybe it's the 90s
anyway we've got a great podcast today
just uh letting you know um we're gonna
get right to it
but uh please subscribe if you're
listening today for
the leslie jordan um and you like the
podcast i'd love for you to subscribe
and listen other episodes you might just
learn something you might like it so uh
tell them whether
they could do that uh inside if you
caught on twitter inside of you podcast
on instagram and facebook
youtube.com inside of you with michael
rosenbaum if you want to
watch it yes absolutely you can watch on
youtube or listen
all those places ryan just said and uh
make sure if you'd like to
the podcast if you want to if you like
it you want to um
join patreon to support the podcast a
little more just go to patreon.com
inside of you p-a-t-r-e-o-n patreon it's
like a big family and it's become
a lot of friends friends ha friendships
have uh
uh what's the word spawned i was gonna
say spawned
i really was gonna say spawned which is
an odd word but
i was going to say spawn it is respond
um so go to patreon there's so many
great things about that
uh you could ask me questions on a
segment you get to ask the guest
questions you get
packages every few months with a signed
autographed by me and a little note from
me
but hey it's been a great week i hope
you guys are rocking and let's get into
this episode this is uh
a guy who you know from will and grace
he's also got
uh millions and millions of followers
his his following has just exploded
hasn't ryan yeah all of a sudden he
found a place on instagram
he's got more followers than anybody i
know i mean really i mean people just
love watching his tick tocks and his
instagram i wish i i hope i'm not
vivacious when i'm
you know in my 60s i don't i don't think
i am now
but uh he really tells it all he does
he's got a book out he's
uh he's pretty magnificent he's uh
just a a little ball of fun a little
ball of fun
and um very likable a likable guy
and i think you're gonna really enjoy
this and he talks about everything so
why don't we just get into it let's get
inside of leslie
jordan it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
you like recording in your bedroom i
noticed leslie this is where the action
happens that bad ain't say no actually
that's not true you have a love life
don't you i do i don't talk about it
it's a long long
five-year affair that's insane and crazy
and i'm not allowed to talk about it
because you
you would faint i could whisper it to
you but
so you've had a hot flaming loving
relationship for five years that's been
pretty intense that you can't talk about
it's like a vanity fair article wedding
happened
did anyone does the other person is he
just he won't let you say anything he
doesn't want it out there
he's just very um you would know with
his job and everything
he's got a very very high pressure job
and stuff and it's more it's more about
that
we really can't go there well i'm glad
that you're fulfilled you seem like
you're uh you know you're fulfilled i
guess
i'm fulfilled very fulfilled everything
you know i i lay in bed at night and i
can't
i want to make a list i'm perfectly
happy with who i am
what i am i have no worries
none my family you know the
the funnel ring and my identical twin
sisters was like
mother's got to go in the hospital and
get they're gonna they're gonna shock
her heart
i said what well it's not even a really
bad procedure i've just talked to her
and they do they go in and just shock it
get it back on rhythm
and it's not that big a deal and i got
her to laugh
i said were you've shocked me for years
and blah blah blah
and so you know 87 year old mother in
good health family and good health
a couple of dollars in the bank you know
it's just
what can you ask for well it's funny
because we have a segment we just
started called well it's like your your
book's called how you all doing but we
have a segment called
how you doing how you doing
and it's a mental health check-in and so
you kind of answer that you feel like
mentally
mentally you feel pretty damn good i do
and i um
i have not always been that way i've had
drug problems i've had
you know i look back on my drug years
and alcohol years started at 14 it was
an easy it
i remember the first thought when i got
high
how easy it was to be gay how
you know how how first of all i had
never
used drugs and and i'd always been kind
of awkward
and and it was that i had this secret
but it wasn't the kind of thing that i
needed to worry about
i i don't think people would have cared
even back then
when i ended up telling people in high
school i said listen i've got a deep
secret
i'm gay and they're like yeah
[Laughter]
and the secret is you're like a gay
murderer
is there more to this secret
and so but anyway when i when i finally
um you know came to terms with that
it was like i am
i knew you know i just didn't have any
problems with it it's weird you know i
i fell out of the womb i landed in my
mother's high heels and so i've always
been
you know comfortable with myself and
that was this other little thing
so anyway how old are you how old are
you leslie
66. and you're so vibrant i see you
dancing your ass off on the instagram
and
by the way 66 isn't old you're not old
but 66 is still
for someone to be dancing around and
having as much fun as you are i think
people
it's pretty obvious i think they're
envious they're like they want your life
especially at your age people say god
how could this guy be so happy
well here's here's my mantra happiness
is a choice
happiness is a habit and happiness is
something you have to work for
and i work really hard i i know
that i have problems with sugar so i eat
right
you know i know that i have problems you
know
i eat right i exercise it's either the
mirror
i was gifted with this wonderful thing
called the mirror
which is a huge yup life-size mirror
they put me through my paces and i fuss
at them they can't hear me
he says do one more i say [ __ ] you
i know you're talking about like i have
one that's an echelon where
they sit there and they talk to you and
they go all right five more reps and you
can sit there and say what you want
because obviously they can't hear you
but i either do my mirror i swim i love
to swim i just did 10 laps
you know i do something i eat right i
sleep
i decided when i was 60 years old that
at six o'clock
the curtain goes down and all my friends
go what do you mean i go exactly what i
said
and i mean it and they go no no no we're
gonna go have dinner no
i'll have lunch six o'clock the curtain
goes down i'm getting ready by nine
o'clock
everything's unplugged 10 o'clock down
you know i i sleep and i can sleep
10 hours so wow
i mean you can really turn off you
you turn your [ __ ] off you turn all your
electronics off like they're
done an hour before you go to bed or
something yeah
i have to because you could be addicted
to that i turn the tv off i turn
anything off i turn
i wander and then i get you know get it
get ready to get into bed and i've
usually got a book
i'm reading and you know what else i'm
very very lucky in that i
i do not know the feeling of loneliness
i'm not lonely
ever really i felt it some when i was
younger but
as i've gotten older especially you know
i talk to friends and then i just
so lonesome i want somebody i don't
i got somebody well that's the
difference you got somebody
that's why they're lonely they they
don't have anybody if they're lonely
and you're like well i'm not lonely
because i have someone
well he adores me and i adore him but
we're in separate cities
so right you said happiness is uh a
habit
so are you saying you create
what is that what does that mean it
means that you make a habit of it you
know in other words if you wake up every
morning and say
[ __ ] what is it if if you create good
habits if you get up in the morning and
say okay how could i make this a great
day
what you know i've got this to do i got
this to do like i don't want to do this
but i got to do it well you got to do it
you know and
you make a habit of not um you know
not going there and you make a habit of
getting up and smiling and
and saying hello to people and you know
just all that [ __ ]
little merry sunshine this little merry
sunshine
but i am i try to make a habit of being
happy
you know that's what i want to be just
like you want to have a habit of
yeah no i think it's important and then
it'll just kind of happen that's where
you'll go
you're grateful you go to bed you say
your gratitude you're grateful for that
that's another word that's what they
teach us in recovery
i'm 22 months you know off the sauce and
that's
that's part of it alcohol alcohol no
alcohol
and no drugs and no cigarette is a big
part of it
you know that's hard to get off that
stuff isn't that hard was it very
difficult for you to get off that
uh on 12 days in the men's central jail
that's all it took
in the men's central jail what what
happened at the jail that you decided i
can't do this anymore
i was sitting there and um the judge had
said
uh i'm gonna give you if you mess up
i'm gonna give you 120 days
and i messed up and i showed up back in
there and i got 120 days
in the men's central jail and um
i was you know people think that it's uh
i don't know i had a friend a gay friend
who said was it erotic
erotic did you see people showering
like mean prisoners i go no
i saw ugly fat people nasty
ugly people and it wasn't funny and it's
like the playground and they were mean
to me
but you know it's what happened after i
got to jail
that made the big difference i i gotta i
did my time
and when i got out i got my first job
and it was on caroline in the city
i remember the show and i had never
worked completely sober
i mean not that i was ever really loaded
at work
but i was either coming off of some
weekend bender or looking forward
anyway i went to my sponsor at the time
and i said listen
i'm i don't know how to work i don't
know what to do
it's okay i'll tell you something you
show up to be of loving service
i so that's a bunch of pablum that's
[ __ ] what about hippie i'm gonna
show up
look of loving service what am i sure
with
he said no no no now listen to me i want
you to show up and be of service
to your director this means that you
have your lines
learned this means that it's his project
it's his story he is the director you as
the actor are allowed to bring things
you know on board but you are of service
to a director
you're of service to producers
therefore you are on time you don't make
waves
you know you you show up you you're
you're a worker among workers
they said you're of service to your
fellow actors which means you don't
steal the show
he gave me this whole list so i show up
and i and the first day i got to this
little tiny script supervisor i wish i
could remember her name
she whispered in my ear she said a
little bird told me you're getting sober
she said i've 35 years you need any
advice or anything you come my way
sit by me i thought wow
i said well i'm supposed to be of
service she goes yeah yeah i know
i know so i was of service for caroline
in the city and i'm telling you it
changed the way i worked today
i don't think about it today but people
use me over and over because
i don't make waves i show up i have my
lines learned
i you know i'm a actor among actors
i don't you know i i do my job and and
directors know that they can
um they can uh rely on you
they can rely on you that was probably
the biggest gift getting sober gave me
because you know you don't think like
that when you're
you know so when you're not sober
were you more ornery or did you did you
ever get angry
um when you were drinking because you
look like someone
who doesn't get angry at all no i do and
i'll tell you why
it's it's all chemical sugar
the blood sugar and the alcohol gets
your blood sugar going and i am the
life of the party and my friend can do
he said you will
turn on a dime he said you'll turn on me
like a mother-in-law
he said we'll be just talking and all of
a sudden you'll go hey listen
it's not always about you and every time
that we or drake and my friend will say
let's say we go through this every time
we promise i go no no no i don't want to
fight
i just want you to know that it's not
always about you
and i would fight
and then i drank in a bar down on santa
monica boulevard ruffle bar because i
liked
rough old boys back then you know uh
the kind you pay to go home with it was
rough
and and they used to say you can always
tell when leslie's working there's not a
boy on the boulevard
doesn't have on brand new chin issues
and the guy benji that was the bartender
because i would hit him
i had a temper slap him
wait a minute so you you you like these
tough
big guys and you'd come at them and a
lot of times they didn't want anything
to do with you and you'd still come at
them
well they'd be happy we were talking you
know about something and and then it
would just turn i don't know
and i'd smack them like a girl would
snack
you know and benji would grab me before
the guy could get to me and lock me in
the
um where they kept the beer in the back
i got a timeout
i had to sit back you just looked for
trouble you were looking for trouble
and i'd been just said i'd knock on the
door
and open it about this so i said benji
go get in there
no you're not can't come out yet and he
said i go
i love you did you ever pay benji a
visit after you got sober and just to
say hey i got it
but i see him he doesn't work there
anymore it's not it's not even there
hunters is right next to the the
avocado hamburger place that's so famous
that sweets are i think
on santa monica boulevard there's fat
burger
that was the corner right there that was
the corner right there there was hunters
and all those old rough cars
we're talking the 80s we're talking
about we're talking long long time ago
and that's when the boys worked the
boulevards see they would work the
boulevard
they had crack habits 40 so they had to
turn a
trick to get their crack and so they
were very busy
you know it's a busy busy time
hey do you let me ask you do you think
people obviously they look at you and
they're like oh my god this guy's
hysterical he's so funny we gotta hire
him we gotta get hired to do all these
funny roles
is there a part of you that wants to do
more drama do you think you could
handle something really dark and
something where you just are completely
the opposite of
who people think you are i do i had a
professor
in college was really rough on me
he told me later on i couldn't
understand why it's so rough on me it
wasn't rough on everybody else
but i couldn't do anything right you
know and he finally pulled me aside
after the four years and he said do you
know that you're capable of genuine
artistry
no i don't i do not know that that's
where you are
you're that good of them but you are so
lazy
i have never seen an actor as lazy as
you
and no matter how hard i've tried you're
gonna end up on some sitcom and you're
gonna do really well but no one will
ever know
wow and i thought wow when i was hired
to do
um the uh american horror story
the first season i didn't know jessica
lying i didn't know anything
i showed up on set down in new orleans
and i had flown i wasn't even in la i
was on another job so i just kind of
flew in real fast
and i turned around and they said leslie
have you met jess and i said jess
i laughed in her face i said oh my god
[Laughter]
i said you play that bird you're the
main one
she goes yeah oh my god i said with
sarah paul
i said it's like it's like a
kindergarten where there's two apples
were you just excited well i remember
thinking what my professor told me and i
thought i know how to work
i know how to work i can do this
and i buckled down you know and i i
pulled it out of my ass
and you know what ryan murphy has used
me over and over and over not really big
parts but
he'll stick me in when he needs that
kind of comedic
uh relief but still serious love to
murder me oh i can't tell you
[Laughter]
but um we uh that's
that's when it i figured out you know
that that's because i'm the funny guy
that comes in with the zinger
you know like on will and grace that's
my job
i've done it i want an emmy doing it i
got that in there
i do it i do but but i'm i'm i'm really
privileged to have someone like ryan
murphy my friend dale schwarz writes
things for me
every once in a while you know somebody
will think outside the box
and there's one out there i want to be
like mickey rooney playing that um
that mentally challenged guy or
something in his late
70s something's going to come along
where people are going to go oh my word
jim
yeah i've got it in me have you ever
grown a beard
or a mustache ever oh yeah in high
school
[Music]
inside of you is brought to you by geico
i'll tell you what ryan whether you you
rent your home i own my home
we've talked about this well first of
all it's hard enough to pay your rent
it's hard enough to pay for your
mortgage
and the last thing you want to do is pay
three different people for your auto
policy your homeowners
renters so geico makes it easy
they have a bundling policy man geico's
a name that you know and you trust
and they make it easy for you it's geico
easy folks all you have to do is this
you go to geico.com you get a quote
and you see how much you could save it's
pretty easy they bundle your homeowners
renters insurance along with your auto
policy like i said and
i i don't know about you but i don't
really like to leave my house or i don't
like to leave as much as possible so
it just makes it a lot easier just go to
geico.com it's geico easy
even a rose and bomb can do it inside of
you is brought to you by better help
better help online therapy uh they've
been a sponsor for quite a long time i
think it's because it's working i think
as people start to believe that um
therapy works and i think that's why
it's working that's why they've been a
sponsor for a while because i think you
know even ryan here
got with better help and how you doing
they're doing doing all right so far
you kind of dig it right yeah it's kind
of nice to talk to someone other than
your girlfriend or your best friend
that they could be you know somebody
could be objective who's a professional
it is nice to have an objective third
party
uh to talk to that's great say uh look
as we begin to see the light at the end
of the
covet tunnel a lot of people are still
feeling down um
and emotionally out of sorts you may not
feel depressed or at a total loss but if
you're feeling a little bit off or your
relationships are suffering
it could be a sign you should talk to
somebody online therapy can help a
better help is pretty simple
uh if you want to get help all you do is
fill out a questionnaire to help
better help assess your needs and match
you with a professional
licensed therapist so many people have
asked me does this stuff really work
the answer is yes it's just uh i i don't
even hesitate
um it's something i've been doing for a
long time
um being able to talk to someone just
you start out your day better i like to
do in the morning some people like to do
it at night
at the end of a stressful day i i
particularly like the morning so
it's kind of like you're tired you're
fatigued you're already stressed you're
already
upset about something and you get
everything out of your system and you
start your day
but to each his own once you fill out
the questionnaire you start
communicating with your therapist in
under 48 hours
schedule secure weekly video phone or
even live
chat appointments the therapists have a
broad range of expertise that may not be
locally available in your area
log into your account anytime to send a
message to your therapist
betterhelp is committed to great matches
so it's easy and free to change
therapists if needed yeah and it's more
convenient it's more affordable
than in-person therapy and financial aid
is available let me tell you something
i've done
in person and those are astronomically
high they charge you an arm a leg and a
couple other things
and better help is certainly fair the
price is to me astonishing how low it is
our listeners today get 10 off their
first month to betterhelp.com
inside that's better h e l p
dot com slash inside
for ten percent off their first month
you should have had a mustache when you
sang at the granola opera in that blue
suit that would have been sweet
can you believe that just came out of
the sky that was just humbling
i was asked it started out here in l.a i
was
asked to do the cover of a magazine
called alpha
it's fairly new it's and so
there was this wonderful uh crystal
wonderful uh um stylist that started
just putting things on me
put that blue suit on but it didn't have
any of the acrylic
you know i had none of that it was just
a blue suit
she told me it was from gucci and so i
believed her and then later on
i was telling everybody in nashville you
know this is a gucci she said i was
kidding
it's a wrangler
but anyway so she um during during the
middle of that i was asked to sing at
the granddaughter
because i had been doing sunday him
singing with my friend travis howard
yeah
and mike lotus uh produced it for us and
danny myrick and
it got to be really big we just sang
these old southern things
in the studio every sunday so we threw
together an album called companies
coming
which got released and we made a list of
everybody we want to sing with from
eddie vader to dolly parton
they all said yes so here we
went so we've got i've got an album out
right now called companies coming
i've got to do it with uh eddie vetter's
going to win a grammy
wait wait why whoa you have a duet with
eddie vetter and
are you singing a hymn we're singing an
old ham it's a
not a hymn it was written in the format
of a hymn
it was written for eddie it's called he
who hideth me and it's about this sort
of universe you can call it gods you can
call it whatever
but whatever it is we'll take he will he
she whatever
will hide of me will take care of me
it's the most
beautiful song you have ever you can
hear it right now
we released it last week all right guys
listen you got to listen to this how do
you not want to hear leslie jordan with
eddie vedder you have to get this
immediately i know i am right after this
leslie jordan
with dolly parton i mean how are you not
star struck
when you meet dolly parton well you're
beyond star struck because the first
thing you think that
she might be a little bit of a joke or
something she's a she's as smart as a
wheel
she's as smart as a whip and she looks
right at you
and talks to you and it she's she's
everything you think she would be that
little tiny waist and that
butt she's got this little bug this
little dolly party
she's 75 years old and looks like a
million dollars
and she has been dolly since the 50s you
know how these girls have changed their
hairdos and their hair styles and
put the skirts up the skirts down to
this that not dolly
she found her look and she's been with
it and she's so smart
and so good you know they're just people
that are just
good she's still to this day at 75 years
old still can sing
i told her i said dolly i went and saw
you in 1973. she said you did not you
know better
i said no i did i said i live in
chattanooga tennessee
you were up in seville tennessee you
sang at the high school auditorium she
said
that was the year jolene came out and i
did sing at the high school auditorium
but you weren't there you made that up
and i said uh
okay i'm gonna give you opening line hey
everybody
i'm dolly parton what's a country girl
without her haystack
cuz
but what's it like when you're singing
with her when you're well you don't get
to sing anymore with
people cause of code but i don't know if
it's the future of the recording
industry but you
lay your track down right the closest i
got was to tanya from one of my songs i
got tonya tucker we were
in in the studio but we were separated
by glass
um i didn't get anywhere near eddie he
was in hawaii and laid his down there
um i didn't get anywhere near randy
carlisle or
well hang on a second do you lay your
vocals down first and then they go in or
was it vice versa
the reason that we do that i think is so
that they can
because they're the better singer i
think really they can do
more with harmony and this and that
and then but there's a lot of going back
and forth like i'll go back
in dolly tall the whole time
well in this way don't you love this
leslie and i had to go back in and
answer her
she talked and then she loved her
i'm on my way and then she touched it
they said this is so much on these hands
make me feel good and
blah blah but her whole family staying
on myself on my album
my album's going to winter and wait a
minute and so she'll talk then you'll go
back in the studio and you have to write
something that sounds kind of
conversational i have to just answer her
answer whatever she said or what
it's amazing what those engineers can do
man wow they can find that one there's a
lot of auto tune going on
um dolly even said to me at one time
dolly said now listen when i can't when
when my family and i were doing this
there's one where i
did my own harmony so when we do this
live we will have to get someone from
the back up to i said
this life it had never crossed my mind
that i might stand on a stick
well you might be going to the grand old
opry sometime again and singing with her
i just said oh my god dolly and
and so uh we'll see we'll see
see i'm not a good singer i'm a hand
singer i'm just a hen singer i grew up
singing hymns and there's a way which
like my mother said leslie just sing out
for the lord
that's all you care about you just
singing for the lord
so you didn't care you just went and
went back and just let it out
can you give me a little bit of i'm
working on a building for my lord that
you're saying from the grand ole opry
i'm over if i was a liar i'll tell you
what i do
i just keep online and start working on
oh my lord oh my lord
i love it and and osborne one of the
osborne brothers he looked at you and
goes you're stealing the show
that's what he said to you by the way on
your instagram i thought it was
hilarious you were talking about
speaking to dolly parton you're talking
about dolly barton part in your goat
the goat story he had a goat named dolly
that had those great big milk sacks that
was sweetest little dog
i don't tell you how to end to the
coyote scutter but anyway
it did not end well this was out in
fresno california
she'd wander down the shed row with her
little
milk sacks swaying and she was cute as
everything was bleeding
and uh she kept the horses calm a lot of
a lot of horse tables will have goats
and pygmy goats around they just kind of
calm the horses but she figured out it's
it's
you have no idea how hot it is we were
actually a little town called madera
how hot it is she figured out if she
went into the bathroom and
flushed the toilet the warm water rolled
out in cold water she got her cold drink
so the guys were delivering the hay and
here she kind just honoring down here
comes gossip work
there's old dolly parton well she went
in the bathroom
you heard a few minutes you heard it
flush and she came out
and i thought she had gone to the
bathroom the guys delivered the hay
one of them looked over me said no way
dolly's with it oh my god
do you love all the attention that you
get on instagram do you just really i
mean
are you surprised still when you see a
hundred thousand two hundred thousand
views and likes and do you feel like
this is an audience that you have to go
keep going back on stage and and give
them love and
enjoy i do i feel also i like the fact
that i would say out of my
almost 6 million followers over half of
them had never seen me on television
because for all these 40 years i've been
working in tv and so people
knew me as my roles you know what i mean
and i'm like willing bryce i'm kind of
snarky and
this and that so that means that all
these other people that i've talked to
because i said did you know me on tv no
i
i discovered you here on the internet
i've discovered me
just me you know and i love that that
that
they keep coming back just to hear me
and um it's what a wonderful thing it is
instagram keeping everybody i'm sure
with kids it's like
you have kids that never look up ever
you don't know what they look like for
kids but anyway
what a wonderful way to to reach out to
one another and
you know there's there's the bad side of
it but the good side to
you know keep in touch and uh this and
that
and i i just love the the fact that
um so many people you know i couldn't
believe it when i had twenty thousand i
said
some people wanna hear what i've said
and then here they came
just millions who are these people have
you ever thought of having your own talk
show
i have but you know what i'm better i
like
i like acting and i'm afraid that goes
away see once you get that talk show
they never get and i really really enjoy
acting like on this little sitcom i've
got
i i just wait i it's the best job i ever
had call me cat
and mayam bialik is our executive
producer she's an actress on it as well
which doubles the fun because she knows
what actors
need to work and here we are over an
empty warner brothers by the way right
now is empty
you drive is so sad to drive onto an
empty
not soundstage an empty lot there's
nobody there
and then you park in your little given
spot and you walk into an
empty sound stage the makeup people have
shields and they have to wear white
jumpers and they make you up and then
they put you back
in your shield and everything and you're
put back in your room
but you sit in that dressing room
forever and then the
cameras get ready and there's nobody
there and we make comedy with no
laughter
because see there's nobody that our kind
of show should have been multi-cam
and should be shooting in front of an
audience and it'll be years i think i
really do think it will be years before
but an audience and so there's no
audience
and the you know the the i tell the
cameraman i'm laughs
yes and all you ever hear is the writer
the one writer over there that
wrote that joke
it's always that one guy it's also
that's it must be his episode that's his
episode
that's his joke
is it hard for you to me one time and
then they add the laughter
i said to him they said you're you're
taking a beat here you don't need just
goes right here because here's the laugh
and i said no i feel this is the laugh
they go
the life is where we put it and we're
gonna put it there
oh my god hey how you all doing is the
book that's out now right
yeah yeah is that your is that look at
that leslie jordan how you all doing
what does it say
tiny by the way i don't know when you
first get it you'll notice it's a shiny
little book
it's an easy read right easy read it's a
very easy read
and what do you get into what do you
talk about well i start out
um about the instagram and how i wasn't
used to that and how that enhanced my
comedy and what i learned to
uh go on the instagram and get ever get
a story that i thought would take
forever on
stage down to a minute and uh how i was
able to find a
beginning middle end and it enhanced it
and how
anyway how my comedy began to work so
well under
the that and then um i just
had 11 i was very lucky see they came to
me
l keck e-l-l-e-k-e-c-k
miss l miss l keck one of the big
editors
at um what who is
not william morris my publishers are
miriam webster no i don't know uh no the
other ones
r ryan do you know what collins oh my
publishers at harpercollins
big one came to me
set up a phone interview and they said
we see a book
we see it coming from your delightful
instagram post
and we see a name we want to we want to
call it how y'all doing
they came to me with a book a name and a
big sack of money
really i said my gosh
that much and now they
said start writing and we like this
story this story
it was already beautifully organized i
called them in about a month and i said
well i got something
something for you and they go but he got
a chapter for us to read i said no i got
the book
how many pages is this book my book
after all these acknowledgements
is 195 you guys could read that quickly
look at that
and i bet it's a bundle of laughs i laid
it out
i kind of liked the way they laid it out
they laid it out
even though i would have a story they
would take the story and make it into
several little stories that got a little
you know well anyway they got little
uh pictures of of uh uh
like this you know there would be part
of the story and then
i like pictures that's how i read i need
pictures
i need pictures you know that'd be a
little piece of like glasses oh look at
that
leslie's glasses in there they'd break
it out yeah and then and then this
another story would continue within the
story so it is an easy read
didn't your mom what's the first lines
that your mom got upset with and said
that's vulgar was that that book
yes well [ __ ] was the first line in it
she said you weren't raised that was son
why why would you
well and i said oh i was just being
silly mom i just said where
it's not that bad of a word she said
well you want rice you know to talk like
that and i said
bought you a condo
inside of you is brought to you by got
pet products the family behind charlie
bear is also behind a human ingredient
company that has been bringing
expertise creative imagination and a
passion for food to people for more
than a century their dog treats their
hound in gatosk it's certainly
phenomenal as you can see my little
blanche eating it has it every day
and i always feel like if you're gonna
give yourself a quality meal give
your animal a quality meal charlie bear
treats are just wonderful
i just sent some to uh jennifer love
hewitt she just
loved them yeah name drop do you see
that i name dropped uh
charlie bear treats are natural dog
treats from our family to your best
friend they're made in the usa
simple natural ingredients low calorie i
think they have like three calories or
less in each one
pocket friendly friendly so they're not
going to like you know crumble and make
a mess in your pocket which i love that
because i have
so much crap at the bottom of my shorts
and jeans their pockets
um wallet friendly you get high value
rewards and most importantly
your dog your dog's gonna love them
and that is a guarantee from me look for
charlie bear products at your favorite
neighborhood pet stores and online
visit our store our website is
www.charliebear.com that's charlie
c-h-a-r-l-e-e-bear
dot com for more information and you can
also go to www.houndgatos.com
hound h-o-u-n-d-g-a-t-o-s
and you're going to get the wonderful
food that blanche eats as well
so check it out a little shout out to my
brother adam
who works for got pet products and all
the boys there and all the girls
and just saying thank you for making my
little blanchy so happy
inside of you is brought to you by
untuck it guys
summer is here summer's here there's
never been a better time
than to try on a shirt from untucking
they have performance shirts that wick
sweat
that's right look how great this shirt
looks on me these shirts are designed
for guys that like to have them untucked
so they're not down to your knees like
they're a dress
they look good you feel confident go to
the beach
you go to a barbecue you go on a date
untuck it
the short sleeve button downs and polos
are made to beat the heat
untucked shirts are perfect as we
transition back to the things we've been
missing like
dinners with friends reuniting with
families and vacations
and here's what you do you use the code
inside for 20
off your first purchase at untuckit.com
use the code inside untuck it makes sure
it's designed to be worn untucked they
have fits for all shapes and sizes
and you know what what's that right
untucked offers up to size triple
xl plus they have slim relaxed and tall
fits untuck it ryan has
85 stores nationwide and free returns
and exchanges
just go to untuckit.com
and type in inside for 20 off
your first purchase you said you were
baptized 14 times were you just being
funny
yeah i made a lot of i was baptized a
lot of the years we would go
you know there would be a church camp
that they would give up and
i think oh i'd like to get baptized in
the lake would have it out there
but i didn't get baptized 14 times but
every time that the preacher would say
would the lost center please come
forward
i would think to myself you know i've
been having bad thoughts about those
boys
and thinking about boys you know
i'd go forward and i had that secret you
know that that i couldn't tell anybody
and i was a good kid and i was a good
little christian boy who just
kept going forward but um it shows how
kids today and i work with so many lgbtq
lmnop wherever it ends today
kids and i work with them and how they
learned to hate themselves
in the pew of the church no matter what
religion it was you know catholic or
you know even buddhists and muslims you
know they just learned
that hate and i i my hero right now is
brandi carlisle the singer because she
calls herself she says i'm a gay woman
of faith
she said when you're a gay woman of
faith you have had to work
so hard to hold on to that faith
to find out what that faith is about
because you've been told this and you've
been read this
you have to with you and your god you
know
you have to you know she speaks it so
eloquently i can't but
you're doing a good job we have to if
we're going to be
gay people of faith which i like that
i'm comfortable with that
for a long time i went back to
alcoholics anonymous
and i would go to the meetings and
garner
garner comfort because i was just used
to meetings but those aren't even
like now you know that's i need more
than even that than an aaa meeting i
need to
you know i need to check in but um
yeah it's it's tough because we've been
raised and taught
and and and you know nobody would listen
well it's tough enough you know growing
you know as a kid just growing up and
being in high school and there's these
clicks and you know you don't fit in
and i was too you know i was short i
didn't i didn't have a lot of friends i
wasn't popular but then
you're in the small town you're in when
you're in chattanooga and
you're christian and in the bible it's
telling you that oh well these are
sinners
and you're thinking that's me but i
don't know
i'm having these thoughts but i can't
control myself i mean that's got to be
i mean just the utmost in horrible
experiences as a kid i mean and you
couldn't talk to anybody right
i talked to my mom when i was 12 i told
my mom and and
she listened and i thought for sure
she'd pull out her bible we didn't even
have a name i didn't know gay
i'm not queer i didn't know what it was
i didn't know what i was trying to tell
her
she understood you know the light she
had to stay with
she took a very deep breath and she said
leslie if this is the path you choose
which now
i mean i didn't choose there was no i
fell out of the womb and landed
and you know her high heels there was no
choice anywhere never once did i sit
down and make a choice
why would someone choose to be something
that society's gonna
make fun of you but she said if you
choose this then
if i was you i would live a quiet life
you know because if not i'm i'm afraid
that you would be subject to ridicule
and i could not bear that i couldn't
bear it
and i thought oh that's so sweet and so
i just laid her quiet last year
so you totally listened to her i took
her
you know now 50 50 yards of purple
chiffon come flying out of my house
oh my god hey uh you ever get starstruck
who makes you star struck who's the one
person you really just go holy [ __ ]
um jessica did because jessica
jessica lange was a star and she kept
you know tours usually you've met on so
many i was
really i worked with dustin hoffman many
many years ago
on the movie i was so struck with him
and he just adored me he kept coming
over
whispering things to me and getting me
in trouble and
he wanted me to he was at odds with the
director of the picture
he knew the picture took place in
chicago he goes you've got a pretty good
southern accent you are late on big
and i said okay i will it's like the
director would come over and say
why are you laying your southern this is
chicago and i said
um that's
no don't and so then that's what come
with
what he said to you i said well he told
me not to because do it thicker
you think as you can i'll take care of
your promise
so i've
were you always a prankster were you in
high school you were a class clown were
they always like
you know cause i was that guy like
rosenbaum go do that go say that get in
trouble
were you that guy who would do anything
for a laugh no i i had my own ways of
getting laughed you know i
i if i was trying to get the laugh and
it looked like i was trying to get the
laugh i wasn't comfortable i was able to
just kind of get the laugh
i tell you one time george clooney was
such a prankster
i worked with him and he went to the uh
wardrobe department he said does he wear
the same suit every day we did a series
called bodies of evidence
long before he did even er it was he
wasn't even well known
but i had such a question because he was
so handsome and so
uh oh i just hope joel which george
and so he said he told him in the
order department take his pants out one
inch every day
just pull out a one inch so i i was on a
diet
and i've been on this diet and i've been
telling everybody about it and
so i say remember that god i told you
that
i didn't lose any pounds i weighed
myself
[Laughter]
i was telling him i said yeah it's a
miracle that it just sheds away
sheds away you really were buying into
it thinking you're losing all this
weight and george clooney was just
[ __ ] with you
laughing every day hey this is called
[ __ ] talking with leslie jordan these
are my patrons
who who uh i love and they have some
questions this is from leanne p
as things are starting to open up after
the quarantine what are you looking
forward to doing the most
he's now i'm just a bit i love to eat at
restaurants
and i yeah by myself you know some
people say oh i could never do that
all the time i don't think twice as long
as you're sleeping
as long as before 6 p.m you don't as
long as i'm looking forward to getting
back out to eating out at restaurants
kelly s i love your sunday morning hymn
session with travis howard how did you
get your passion to perform those
gospel songs you sound wonderful well
because i started singing from the time
i was
two or three seriously two or three
years old we would sing those old hymns
and in the baptist church sometimes if
there's not enough hymnals to go around
the preacher will
say the words kind of quite you know uh
and you know this little uh
you know so this little animal and so i
knew
i knew the words and when uh
i found an old baptist hymn and when i
opened it up to show travis
we just about sprang because we knew
every single word it was the fabric of
our childhood
it was everything we had ever heard
growing up you know
and not that we believed it or didn't
believe that it didn't matter it was
just the
words you know and and the tombs
and i don't care if you're you know
jewish or muslim or but
buddhist or christian or how you were
raised this music
is wonderful i'm hoping people will just
take it for what it is
you know we're not proselytizing by any
means
little lisa says leslie could you please
tell us about one of your favorite
behind-the-scenes moments on will and
grace
something that no one's heard maybe well
this is going to kind of tell on myself
but before i started on will embrace
people came up to me and said that megan
malone was brilliant
you may have met your manager
she may be funny but honey she's no
luster so
you know we went to rehearsal and she
didn't do beat that
voice during rehearsal much you know and
she
she's she's like me she loves business
she's going to pick up
a drink and talk she's going to do it
and she's going to have
when she says that work she that's how
she memorizes i think she's like me
she likes she likes her business she's
also not going to like a lot of
preparation
she won't you know i said you want to
run lines no
but anyway we walked you know in front
of an audience
and i said my line well well
and just uh the house just hollered
hollering
and all of a sudden i turned around and
looked at her and a
comedic tsunami it was a tsunami
hit me with whatever her next line was
and that place went ballistic and she
looked at me like
okay and i looked at her like okay
and it was like the sun and you know we
we're not good friends really we don't
hang out with each other but when we're
we are so competitive
on stage and she wins because of those
titties
she always likes i could
if i get the last line and get the big
lick all she's got to do is she'll look
at me
and that's it and that's it
do you think she liked you did you like
each other or you're not really oh yeah
you did no we adore one another you
still talk to each other
it's more than just a mutual admiration
of uh we're both southern she's from
oklahoma city i knew her mother martha
who died recently
and so you know it's uh uh it's that
it's that and then also i you know i
bore her
her husband's so adorable because he's
nine feet you know and she's my
[Music]
you know this person just says steph a
says leslie i just want you to know how
much you mean to me
you're such a genuine and loving person
you've helped me feel more secure in
myself and in my life
from will and grace to now you've kept
me laughing and learning both
lots of love to you isn't that the
nicest thing
oh my gosh yeah i mean you i guess
you're i mean it's infectious i'm glad i
quit snorting crystal man
what's it by the way what's it like uh
snoring i thought that old person could
make something
how does someone get into crystal meth i
mean uh you know
here's how it happened it was it was a
sad situation but it happened in the gay
bars and it happened in the 80s
and it was called tina and it was like
you would do a little damp a little
little bump on the dance floor and it
was better than cocaine because it
lasted so long
but what what happened is you do a big
rail of that tina you're up six hours
and i mean you're a
little you're 10 hours so it's like
speed
it's like speed speed and so everybody
on the dance floor
at the after hours that's the only way
you know you can step to
and put an awful feeling to walk out of
probe
on highland on a sunday morning and see
people dressed for church
happy with their children
oh my god and you're like
i mean
what were the downs though the ups are
so great but the downs are absolutely
the worst
horrendous when you lost people i mean
people the people committed suicide was
like
you know they just didn't think that
it's not like a hangover it's just like
you
you think it's the end of the world it's
just uh
you get and you're very very very
paranoid that's where
when you see um aluminum foil and
windows
and and some weird house painted black
security around you quicker
just and it and it took a really long
time to get my thinking back
i i liked it because
one burp and everything goes slow
everybody else because i'm so hyper
anyway
it just had a chemical reaction on me
where it just slowed me down
and i remember thinking i said to the
guy davidson and jimmy and said can you
get me a little tiny bit of this every
day
like the rest of my life right i'll just
do like a
i'll just do a little bit and then life
will be wonderful well that's what yeah
well that's what adt add medication is
the people who are like i'm
i'm a hyperactive and if i take
something like a vivance or whatever
it slows me down and i'm able to focus
more so
yeah it's the same thing and you begin
to think oh so this
this is normal this is oh my god so this
is the way everybody else is and i've
been up here
yeah these years yeah it's it's hard
everybody
it's hard being up there it's hard being
just always like this because
it's it's calming down it's just it's
just really hard to calm down and then
you get really depressed
when you go home alone and you start to
think about
oh my god what did i do what did i say
why do i always have to be funny i
always have to be the center of
attention why can't i just be normal
what the hell is wrong with me
you would start feeling all right
preaching to the choir yeah
you are preaching but you're through it
now now you're good
i'm through 22 years clean completely
sober and
you know happier than i've ever been and
it's uh
it was a journey that i look back
sometimes and i i think to myself i
don't know that i don't know who that
was
i don't know who that was they stayed up
for six days and then went to a
an audition and the casting director is
now dead
the casting director called me and he
was a gay man thank god
he said um why don't you go home and get
some sleep
i said no i really wanna audition
because you really don't want to
audition
wow you've been up a long time i had
been up
six days and i was gonna try to audition
for this
i even remember the part it was uh
return of the living dead
maybe you would have gotten that one it
was hilarious they wanted an
irish accent which i couldn't do and it
was gonna be
um there was uh what
what's tatum o'neill's dad's
[Music]
what's his name from love love uh with
farrah fawcett yeah
what's his name something ryan o'neill
ryan o'neill i don't know
i was going into the room
he'll know
so well good for him at least
did he didn't tell your agents or
anything did he
that was good well you know what this
has been really lovely this has been
really nice
i've really enjoyed it thank you yeah
was this all right for you did you have
fun
i did thank you for allowing to be
inside of you today and i really enjoy
this conversation i'll talk to you soon
i do and you're
wonderful at what you do you're
wonderful
well definitely interesting he's an
infectious personality i would say
yes i would say that too i think that uh
it's just it's just a combination of the
personality with the accent
he just jumps into things like that and
anything he talks about just seems like
it's funny
like if i just jumped in and i talked
about those things that no one would
think it was that funny no
no he's got a he can make anything funny
he can he fell right out of his mama's
womb into her high heels into a pair of
high heels so that's
brilliant so thank you leslie jordan for
being on the podcast you were uh you're
a fun guest
and um just a reminder if you want to um
subscribe to the podcast
uh you could do that very easily on
youtube or
on spotify stitch or apple please write
a review if you like it
certainly helps the podcast out send it
to your friends um
and you could uh subscribe also the
handles
are on instagram and facebook there what
ryan oh
inside of you podcast on facebook and
then twitter
the twitter's inside inside of your pod
that's correct so write a review
join us join the family also if you want
to join patreon that's a wonderful thing
to help the podcast in other ways i will
send you a message
um it's it's a great thing the patreon
if you haven't if you have no idea what
patreon is i'll just explain it to you
in a few sentences top tiers on the
patreon
get packages from me every few months
they get to ask questions ask me
questions on a segment i have
random spur of the moment youtube lives
with me playing guitar
discounts on the inside of you online
store
you know it's it's a lot of fun and so
many people have become such good
friends through patreon
and uh it just it makes me really happy
so all you have to do is go to
patreon.com
inside of you and become a member today
and i'll write you a message
also the inside of you store why don't
we just go with back surgery 10
for 10 off anything on the inside of you
store we've got small of the lunch boxes
lex luthor pictures uh journal signed by
me funko pops mugs
shirts the list goes on also
mybansunspin.com you go to sunspin.com
and you get all the crazy merch there
you could also get book zooms
with me and rob 10 minute zooms it'd be
fun maybe ryan will be on with those
zoom sometime
i don't know i can't tell you what
ryan's going to do i don't know what
ryan's gonna do
yeah you don't even know what ryan's
gonna do also just uh
if you're writing this down uh i'm gonna
be at comic palooza
just go to comicpalooza.com in houston
get tickets to see me
on july 17th and 18th it's gonna be a
lot of fun so july 17th 18th just go to
comicpalooza.com
and also uh coming down the road in
september i'll be at dragoncon september
4th
tom welling and i will be together
lexington lexington
comic-con uh september 9th welling and i
will also be together
and then west virginia
mountaineercomicon.com
you can go to it's mountaineer comic-con
september 24th weekend
i'm getting going ryan i'm getting going
on these on these um seriously on the
conventions
it's been that's back in high gear yeah
like a year year and a half since i've
been doing it and
certainly i miss it certainly the fans
miss it so i'm curious to see what it's
going to be like
if it's going to be just a [ __ ] show
like you know in a good way like
hopefully there'll be a lot of people
out there just you know
protecting themselves and you know
they're hopefully vaccinated and
uh you know to protect the people around
them and
themselves nonetheless i just i'm
excited to see people
and engage in people i wonder if my
anxiety levels will go up probably a
little
what do you do you just uh i mean have
you been on a on a plane
since the pandemic started yeah once i
went and saw my grandparents that's
right that's right my grandmother sorry
my grandpa's dad thanks for bringing
that up
he yeah looked at me didn't even think
it was funny segway
segway and by the way there's been a lot
of stuff of press
about um the smallville animated series
and it just kind of
went wild and it's because tom my buddy
tom welling said something
well just i don't think it's a big
secret but uh we're working on something
and um i think it's special and
hopefully we'll be able to make it and
we've got some special people
involved and that's all i could say and
uh we'll leave it at that
until i have more news but uh i'll let
you know that i'm doing everything i can
to make uh things come to fruition and
these things take a lot of time so uh be
patient and um
hopefully uh be there when i need you
for support
why don't we do the uh patrons shout
outs these are the patrons
who give a little bit extra a lot extra
and
uh they deserve a shout out at the end
of each show so why don't i do that ryan
uh why don't you why don't you take a
sip here here we go and then do it
nancy d mary b leah s trish f sarah v
little lisa yukiko jill e bryan h
lauren g nico p robin s jerry w robert b
jason w
apothean kristen k emilia o allison l
lucas m raj c
joshua d emily s cjp samantha m
jennifer n stacy l carly h carly s
jen s jamal f janelle b tap of the 272
not to be confused with
the 273. i can't miss that ever i try to
just keep reading but i can't
i can't stop kimberly e mike e eldon
supremo
99 more ramirez santiago m sarah f chad
w liam p
ray a maya p maddie s kendrick f
ashley e shannon d matt w belinda n
kevin v
james r chris h dave h samantha s
spiderman chase
sheila g brad that's what i just
randomly said brad
yeah it's brad brad yeah brad brad d
brad
yeah ray h tap the t tom and suzanne b
liliana a
michelle k marquez i love you marcus w
hannah b
michael s we got talia m andrew t uh
betsy
we've got betsy d we've got clara am
betsy d see i said that i've read it as
an o for some reason because it looks
like an oh cause i can't see very well
with my contacts
last time she let me know she said it's
not betsy oh i go i know it's not it's
best
betsy denafria see did i say that right
because now i'm thinking
vincent d'onofrio betsy denafria
that's it she's gonna kill me who else
we got claire
m liz j laura l chad l rochelle
nathan e taylor k marion and here's the
end of the list but not the worst part
of the list
the faves no med k janelle p trav l
dan and diane r ogetta
that wasn't how you spelled it said it
what was it
ah jetta ah jetta jetta ah jetta
lorraine
g veronica k big stevie w kendall t
carol d sandy b angel m eric c rhiannon
c
stephen m corey k super sam emily c
sherry s coleman g david c michelle a
riley j
matt w liz l jeremy c andy t
cody r chris e sebastian k gavinator
and h elliott m john b and brandy
d that is uh that is all of the amazing
patrons again if you want to join
patreon patreon.com inside of you
join the family today so many people
become such close friends on it and i
love it and uh
i i had no idea that patreon would would
blow up like this but
uh a lot of these people i i call
friends they're just
amazing people and you know you think
sometimes people say
well how do you differentiate between
fans and friends well that's easy you
have to keep them separate but at the
same time
you meet some people who are just
incredibly respectful and
they're not trying to get into your life
they're just they're just become sort of
part of your life in a way
they're just really good people you get
people say do you ever get weirdos
i mean occasionally you do and then you
have to kind of say hey you're i'm
uncomfortable but that rarely happens
people are so respectful
and that really is uh
that's just a cool thing when you're not
when you don't feel uncomfortable at all
i don't feel uncomfortable with all but
any patron
they just for the most part 99 of them
just
[ __ ] good people giving
loving sweet affectionate good folk
giving lovin
uh thank you so much for listening today
this has been a real treat uh hopefully
you enjoyed leslie jordan hopefully
you'll stick around for next week's
episode
um most of the people are sticking
around right now and listening are
people that
uh that love me and i love back anyway
so uh from ryan
taya's here in the hollywood hills from
michael rosenbaum over there
yeah we're gonna look up there and we'll
give a wave to the camera thank you so
much for allowing to be inside of each
and every one of you
um i love being here love uh i love
doing the show and i hope you love
listening
and until next time keep your pants on
[Music]